[Musique]
avec le retour de Michael Elmi Doro et
on connaît le prochain adversaire
Mickael du Paris Saint-Germain en Ligue
des Champions le tirage au sort des
huitièmes de finale de la compétition
tant attendu avait lieu à la mi-journée
au siège de l'UEFA en Suisse et ce sera
un gros morceau pour les Parisiens le
Bayern Munich vainqueur à six reprises
de la Champions League les Bavarois
l'ont emporté en 2021 pour la dernière
fois c'était face au PSG en finale score
final 1 à 0 et 2 équipes se sont
affrontés à 11 reprises dans la
compétition et le bilan est à la faveur
des Parisiens s'y succès contre 5 pour
les Allemands pour ce 8e de finale le
match aller aura lieu le 14 février
prochain au Parc des Princes match
retour à l'alliance Arena de Munich le 7
mars le football on en reparle dans un
instant mais peut-être autour de cette
table moi je suis très mauvais je suis
très mauvais en pronostic mais on peut
demander Mustapha
passe pas ce niveau là moi je suis à la
machine dans le football amateur je fais
pas de à ce niveau là c'est ça me
dépasse
moi je vais pas m'y risquer parce que en
général quand je donne un pronostic ça
va dans le sens contraire vous êtes très
bien on va dire qualification du Bayern
Munich comme ça peut-être on espère du
Paris Saint-Germain parler football dans
un instant mais on va prendre le large
tout de suite nickel avec la Route du
Rhum c'est la course en solitaire qui a
été décalé on le disait tout à l'heure à
cause de mauvaises conditions météo le
départ de cette course a été décalé donc
de dimanche à mercredi 14h15 de
yvelinois seront en cours dans la classe
IMOCA le versaillais Eric Bellion et le
rambolitain Louis Burton qu'on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'interviewer dans
les prochaines heures avant son départ
il est très pris il est sur des
briefings en ce moment météo donc on ne
peut pas l'avoir malheureusement ce soir
peut-être demain
prendra le départ sur la Route du Rhum
ce mercredi
Eric Bellion le versaillé sera engagé
sur cette édition
22 dans la catégorie IMOCA le navigateur
de 46 ans espèrent réaliser une belle
performance pour se préparer pour le
futur Vendée Globe on écoute son
interview express
[Applaudissements]
mon objectif c'est d'être parmi les
meilleurs donc c'est de faire de mon
mieux pour aller le plus vite possible
la Route du Rhum c'est un bateau c'est
une course qui est pas trop faite pour
les bateaux à dérive droite mais bon on
n'est pas à l'abri de bonne condition
climatiques qui nous font aller vite au
début donc moi mon objectif c'est d'être
parmi les meilleurs et donner le maximum
de ce que j'ai ça change jamais donc je
on est trois acteurs il y a l'océan il y
a mon bateau il y a moi et si tous les
trois ben on travaille bien en harmonie
ça devrait bien le faire
[Musique]
le départ est vraiment difficile on peut
y avoir une tempête à passer c'est
souvent c'est le mois de novembre donc
c'est les tempêtes hivernales dans
l'Atlantique donc d'abord il faut passer
cette tempête il faut passer sous le cap
de sous la latitude de Lisbonne et là
après on touche les alizés c'est
beaucoup plus simple même si on est
toujours pas arrivé parce que les alizés
peuvent être compliqués notamment le
matin enlever du soleil là on peut avoir
des grains très très puissants et la
grosse difficulté c'est passé l'hiver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un bateau mythique c'est Hubert qui
a gagné le Vendée Globe en 2007-2008 il
y a le bateau de Jean Le Cam à qui j'ai
loué le bateau et j'adore mon bateau en
sortant super bien et je pense que je
vais être très triste de le rendre à
Jean Le Cam après l'arrivée de la Route
du Rhum
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour cette Route du Rhum dont le
départ je disais était décalé à mercredi
à 14h15 en raison des mauvaises
conditions climatiques Michael on va
revenir aussi sur les autres résultats
du week-end dans les Yvelines et parler
notamment de football oui et par une
très belle performance celle de
Versailles en National les joueurs de la
cité royale se sont imposés 1 à 0 sur la
pelouse de Châteauroux se vend
l'histoire avec une réalisation signée à
Mondi prunier avec ce résultat le FC
Versailles se retrouve à la deuxième
place du classement avec 19 points
engranger en 11 journée le prochain
match des versaillers est programmé ce
vendredi 11 novembre contre le Stade
briochin dernier a du classement très
bonne période pour Versailles d'où cette
invention un peu surprenante Versailles
qui vient de perdre son entraîneur la
nouvelle est tombée ce lundi c'est la
petite bombe du jour on peut le dire
l'entraîneur de l'équipe du FC
Versailles Youssef chibi et mise à pied
à titre conservatoire le club l'a
annoncé aujourd'hui dans un communiqué
officiel sans préciser les raisons de sa
mise à pied coach de l'équipe depuis
juillet 2014 et artisans de la
progression du club jusqu'en national il
aussi emmener le club en demi-finale de
la Coupe de France l'année dernière on
s'en souvient tous Vincent et woman et
l'ensemble du staff actuel prennent en
charge l'équipe pour la réception du
Stade de briochin ce sera donc ce
vendredi 11 novembre pour une nouvelle
journée dans le championnat de National
on va descente d'un étage et parler du
championnat national de en football en 2
Poissy a perdu ce weekend sur le terrain
de Châteaubriant à l'occasion de la 9e
journée du championnat alors qu'ils
avaient marqué en premier par Konaté dès
la troisième minute les pissacées se
sont finalement les deux un à la 87e
minute au classement l'as Poissy est à
la troisième place du championnat à 5
points du leader le Racing Club de
France malheureusement une fin de
parcours en rugby c'est bien triste
Emily Boulard ne sera pas championne du
monde cette année livelinois institut là
avec l'équipe de France a perdu avec ses
coéquipières ce samedi à Auckland en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde face au
néo-zélandaise le score est terrible 25
à 24 les Françaises ont raté une
pénalité à une minute de la fin la
joueuse yvelinoise disputera ce samedi
face au Canada le match pour la à 3e
place sera débriefer un cette
compétition avec elle qui avait été
notamment MVP du quart de finale face à
l'Italie Emily Boulard du rugby masculin
cette fois-ci et on parle du championnat
de fédéral 2 belle performance de
Versailles cette fois-ci en rugby a
décidément Versailles est une ville de
sport et surtout il y a de bons
résultats les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont imposés à 29 à 24 à domicile
face à Boulogne-Billancourt ce résultat
permet au versaillé d'occuper la 8e
place du championnat prochain match ce
dimanche 13 novembre sur le terrain de
Courbevoie il y a un autre club yvelin
dans cette poule de Fédérale 2 alors si
Versailles a gagné plaisir c'est incliné
26 à 21 sur son terrain face à
Courbevoie dans un match disputé on
regarde le résumé du match un reportage
de Nicolas dandry et Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
c'est une défaite avec un goût amer pour
plaisir les jaunes et bleu se sont
inclinés 26 à 21 face à Courbevoie il y
avait la place pour les plaisirsois
campé devant l'mbue de leur adversaire
les hommes de Sébastien ronali n'ont
jamais réussi à franchir la ligne dans
les dernières minutes de la rencontre
pour arracher la victoire je sais pas le
nombre de fautes mais je pense qu'il y
en a bien une dizaine de pénalités
d'affilée à 5 mètres de la ligne donc on
verra tout ça la vidéo mais bon c'est
sur un cumul de fautes comme ça je
comprends même pas comment il y a pas
assez de tonalité comment il y a pas
plusieurs cartons bon enfin vraiment
voilà on est très très très déçu
effectivement par rapport à ça tout
avait pourtant bien commencé pour
plaisir après 20 minutes de jeu les
plaisirs moi-même 14 à 3
[Musique]
Courbevoie recolle au score en
inscrivant un premier essai mais avant
le retour au vestiaire les aiguilles
noires reprennent le large à la mi-temps
plaisir prend de l'avance 21 à 13
revigorer avec plus de maîtrise
Courbevoie réussi son début de seconde
période en 20 minutes les visiteurs
virent en tête 21 à 26
le score restera inchangé jusqu'à la fin
de la rencontre peut-être qu'on se
trouve une fois eu deux défensivement
justement sur le début de cette deuxième
mi-temps ils reviennent dans le match et
du coup bon bah voilà ils sont en
confiance et nous après on est obligé de
courir sur le score à la fin et voilà
quoi c'est peut-être en terme de la
deuxième là qui est regrettable avec son
excellent début de saison plaisir
conserve la deuxième place au classement
malgré cette défaite les plaisirs rois
prennent un point de bonus défensif
prochain match prévu ce dimanche 13
novembre à Domont
plaisir est donc en bonne position pour
terminer dans le top 5 du classement
mais il faudra rester quand même
concentré jusqu'à la fin rester
concentré on l'espère pour pour
peut-être atteindre ces phases finales
dans le championnat de fédéral de un mot
de handball à présent après le rugby le
handball dans le championnat de National
3 plaisirs les clés connus la défaite ce
weekend les hommes de Benjamin modeste
se sont inclinés 30 à 25 sur leur temps
contre Paris Sport Club une défaite
plutôt logique face au leader du
classement au classement justement les
plaisirs les clés dans le milieu du
classement à la sixième place mais c'est
très serré merci Michael pour toutes ces
précisions on va parler encore un peu de
sport et de cyclisme plus précisément
avec le huitième Grand Prix de Vélizy
qui était organisé ce dimanche au
programme vitesse kering scratch course
au point en Vélodrome national de 50 ans
en Yvelines vous avez notamment consacré
un reportage sur ce Grand Prix avec les
images bien sûr de Patrick Jack Denix au
bout de l'effort on attend dauphin
termine deuxième sur cette course au
point organisée dans le cadre du Grand
Prix de Vélizy une compétition
et pour vous dire je fais même
l'endurance aujourd'hui alors que ça
fait très longtemps que j'ai pas fait
d'endurance et donc c'est vraiment pour
m'amuser et me remettre dans le dans
l'ambiance Julie Michaud rejoint la
longue liste des membres de l'équipe de
France ayant participé à la compétition
actuellement tous les pistes
internationaux tricolore ont couru le
Grand Prix de Vélizy un rendez-vous qui
reviendra l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition
[Musique]